போட்டு செய்யவில்லை. இப்போது இதுக்கு யாரும் பொறுப்பு? அவனுக்கு என்ன தண்டனை கிடைக்கவேண்டும்? தண்டனை கிடைத்தால் இது ஒரு விஷயம். இது இந்த ஜன்மத்திலேயே, போனே ஜன்மும் இது நியாயமா?
எப்போது சின்ன வயதில் நான் செய்ததுக்கு இப்ப தண்டனை கிடைப்பது நியாயமா? இவர் நீங்கள் சொல்வது, இப்போது எனக்கு கிடைக்கும் தண்டனையைப்பற்றி நீங்கள் வெங்கக்கையில் எல்லோரும் சொல்கிறீர்கள், கர்மப்பலம் என்று.
நான் சொல்கிறேன் அந்த அக்ஷன் எனக்கு தெரியாமல் நான் இண்டெஞ்சன்னு வைத்துக்காமல் எனக்கு இன்னொரிம்ஸ்ல சின்ன குழந்தைத்தைப் பர்வத்தில் அல்லது போன ஜென்மத்தில் நாம செய்தது
அது கருமாவா, அதுக்கு இந்த தண்டனை அது கொடுப்பது நியாயமா, அப்படியென்பது கிட்டதட்ட நான் ஞானபற்காஸ் கேட்ட கேள்வி
இது என் கடவுள் இந்த திட்டி இது நியாயமா என்றால் நான் அறியாமல் செய்ததுக்கு எனக்கு இது கிடையாது என்று ஒத்திருந்தால்தான் கடவுள் செய்வது அணியாயம் என்று வரும் கருமத்தியரி அணியாயம்
இப்போ அது நியாயம்தான் இருக்க முடியும் என்றால் நான் தெரியாமல் செய்ததோ, நான் செய்தேன் என்பதை எனக்கு மறந்து போனதோ, அது இந்த மாதிரி பாசுமான கர்மப்பலனை கொடுத்தா, அப்போ அந்த கர்மத்துக்கும் இதையும் இணைக்கும் தவறில்லை என்ப முடிவுதான் வந்தாலும் வேற வழியில்லை நமகிடம்
மூன்று மாதமாக வெட்டியாகச் சொல்லிட்டு இருக்கிறான், எல்லா விஷயம் கேட்டேன், எப்போதும் ஆறு வயத்தில் ஏழு வயத்தில் சின்ன வயத்தில் ஏதோ விளையடுப்போதோ, ஸ்கிப்பிங் செய்யுப்போதோ, கீழே விழுந்து காலில் கணுக்கால் ஓர் ஹர்லையின் பிராக்சரா இருக்கும்
சின்னாட்டு வலிச்சுது சரியா போச்சு, பிறகு சின்ன வயது பூடி ஆடியாது மறந்து போச்சு.
இன்று கேட் 40 வயதுல, 10-30 வருஷம் வெளிச்சுயன், அது பெரிச்சா வளர்ந்து வெங்கி வெங்கி போய்,
இப்போது அது எப்படி நியாயம் அது இந்த தண்டனை, நான் எப்படி இதை எடுத்துக்கொள்ள முடியும்,
வயத்தில் ஏதாவது நடந்தது, நான் மறந்து கூட போய்விட்டேன், அதுக்கு இப்படி கிடைக்கலாமா?
அப்படி நாம் கேட்டால் பிறகு அது தெரியவில்லை, அதுக்கு என்ன?
வாழ்க்கை செய்ய வேண்டும். இப்போது நீங்கள் கேட்ட கேள்விகளில் இன்னொரு விஷயம் இருக்கிறது.
அவர் இதை எப்படி எடுத்துக்கொள்ள வே
அவர் இதை எப்படி எடுத்துக்கொள்ள வேண்டும் என்கிறது. நான் ஒரு விஷயத்தைக் கஷ்டம், எனக்கு இது பெரிய கஷ்டம், இது எனக்கு பெரிய சாவம்.